I've been expecting you team top five
who are you relaxing phalange flex what
disarm them alright alright are we doing
this or what yeah we kind of got a
countdown thing to do actually I need
more time to perfect my most evil plan
go on do your last countdown and then I
will deliver suffering in the longest
most evil monologue as with any
franchise that's been around for over 50
years James Bond has developed some
tropes and patterns that the film's have
fallen into a good movie plays with
these elements without drawing too much
attention to them but what happens when
they're omitted from a movie or worse
completely take over these are the top 5
worst James Bond movies number 5
Moonraker very much the best worst Bond
film right away the midair fight
sequence made to look like they're
free-falling without a parachute
is honestly incredibly impressive
especially for the time but then we're
dragged through the rest of this
dizzying movie there's a lot going on to
start mostly bond breaking whatever he
wants but some things are set up that we
don't get back to like check out this
dude that I totally like to know more
about ah but we got to keep the teeth
dude all this leads up to the inevitable
Space Act aboard the space station we
learn the evil plot to wipe out the
earth but saving fully bonds on top of
it turning off the gravity to save the
day well at least no one's shooting oh
my god laser fight I take back
everything this is amazing
it's not a good movie by today's
standards but it's so ridiculous at
points that it becomes fun all over
again it's just so very 1979 and with
the relatively recent success of Star
Wars it was clear that sci-fi was the
way to hook audiences for the Elevens
bond film although it was met with mixed
feelings
Moonraker was the highest grossing film
of the bond series until Goldeneye
so hey joke's on us number four for your
eyes only after the more science fiction
centric Moonraker the franchise tried to
return to a more realistic and grounded
bond honestly this movie isn't too bad
it suffers from some slow pacing in
between action sequences that make it
feel long and it's had unengaging
but when there is action it is well done
with some great stunt work
[Music]
but goodness Bibi is one of the most
annoying characters in the bond universe
I don't call her a Bond girl because
bond actively turns down her advances
probably because of interactions like
this and you ever come up for air get
the gold medal breath control lose the
number one reason this movie gets under
my skin though is the opening sequence
and possibly one of the biggest letdowns
of the franchise
Blofeld is killed off within the first
six minutes of this movie the series had
been building to this moment a final
showdown between spectres number one and
double-oh-seven
finished in five minutes without a
single mention of the aftermath in the
movie now this was due to some
complicated legal issues with James Bond
Blofeld and Spectre were both apart of
the rights dispute therefore he couldn't
be used or mentioned in the movies until
it was resolved Blofeld does not even
mentioned in the credits the audience is
just supposed to assume it's him because
of the white cat and the fact that the
movie begins with Bond looking at his
wife's grave no epic showdown just
begging for his life and a fall to the
death for one of bonds most iconic
villains very disappointing
Octopussy hope you all aren't scared of
clowns because this movie has not only
one but two mi6 agents parading as them
hi I'm not entirely too sure
Octopussy follows the story if a
jewellery counterfeit ring involving a
mysterious island of women and a nuclear
bomb on a US base in order to disarm the
Western nations to pave the way for a
modern-day blitzkrieg confused
sowe're audiences the plot of this film
was all over the place it's like the
movie wanted to be full of twists and
turns to keep you on the edge of your
seats but rather a dragging middle left
you wondering where is this going
Octopussy takes the cheesy charm of a
typical Bond movie way too over-the-top
he's got the most ridiculous gadgets
like a horse trailer airplane and a
crocodile sub it sets up silly gags that
really don't pay off like mentioning a
character as a tennis player just so we
could have this happen
[Music]
or even worse has a jungle chase scene
to set up this gym
[Applause]
there's even a couple of times where I
felt bond was veering into creepy
territory rather than being charismatic
for example he uses one of Q's gadgets
just to zoom in on a girl's cleavage
perfect image cute really wson look I
haven't time for these adolescent antics
charming overall Octopussy misses the
mark on being a tongue-in-cheek campy
Bond movie and instead comes across as
ridiculous and a little awkward number
two of you to a kill right away this
movie started out on rocky footing
you know what the Beach Boys song
California Girls makes me think of a
British man snowboarding in Siberia this
was also my least favorite opening title
sequence
the unenthusiastic neon Painted Ladies
makes me uncomfortable but don't worry
the ladies got more uncomfortable as the
film went on top ski as a reminder Roger
Moore was 57 at the time of filming so
they made sure to age up the henchmen he
had to fight but not the ladies and
bonds geology damsel is laughable
throughout the whole movie is one big
stretch with what stunts bond would be
capable of doing and a lot of the pot
relied heavily on dumb luck
Oh glad they have that jumpsuit in a
double-0 Christopher Walken as Thorin
throws himself out there to make us care
about the microchip Silicon Valley evil
tech it's just not that interesting
beyond killing people in complicated
ways Grace Jones as May Day is far more
interesting though deciding to be good
once double-crossed by an established
bad guy gives the audience whiplash from
extreme excuses to put a stunt double in
a wig - ridiculous deaths this movie
sure was a memorable ride just not in a
good way
and the number one works James Bond
movie
die another day what's most frustrating
about this movie is that the beginning
premise is actually really good James
Bond is captured and in prison in North
Korea after his cover is blown by one of
his own after more than a year he's
traded back to mi6 in a prisoner
exchange but M thinks he's lost his use
as an agent bond goes out on his own to
track down Zhou the North Korea and he
was exchanged for and find out who
betrayed him within his own organization
die another day is the only Bond movie
that upset me all the goofy more movies
or other subpar installments don't
really bother me all that much I at
least enjoy them on some level but this
one literally put me in a bad mood I
just said last week how much I love
Pierce Brosnan as James Bond there's
just something about him that's very
unique from the others while he wasn't
always in the best movies I always liked
him in the role and this I liked him but
they gave him such trash to work with
and the thing is this starts out in some
really different and intriguing
territory Bond is a prisoner for 14
months beaten tortured humiliated when
he's let go in the exchange we have a
really good scene with him and M that
shows off how ruthless she could be you
know used to anyone
bond has something to prove now everyone
has abandoned him and after over a year
of torture he should be a changed man
more merciless a burned agent ought to
get back to what he once was and maybe
make some tough compromises along the
way but after a shave and a haircut he's
just back to being the same guy he was
before not so much as a limp that was
really irritated because we had the
opportunity to take him in a direction
we hadn't seen before besides that the
cast is pretty awful here Halle Berry
looked to be prepping for a role in
Catwoman and the villains were made out
to be complete jokes
combine that with Madonna's horrible
theme song some terrible CG a baffling
Ice Hotel setting and the ending of
Batman and Robin and you have what feels
like a three and a half hour long piece
of frozen diamond encrusted garbage
Brosnan deserves so much better than
this for his last outing as
double-oh-seven
who said you
your mama Oh Walter I have something
especially original for you hmm I wonder
how the other villains have such loyal
aquatic life boss I got a great idea
what if we broke them up I just had a
great idea wonderfully rock them no I
swear to bond one more duplicate tries
to tie me up I will lose my shit no you
can't don't have a we're in love what
even is going on I don't know man
there's so many tropes in I lost count
how about one more trip for the road
danger zone oh yeah baby
[Music]
[Applause]
you